اليوم كمان انه بما انه هذا يجب انه يتم
تعميمه وفي ناس عم طالب تعميمهم هل
المدراء مدراء الشركات وايضا رؤساء
الاقسام منفتحين على هذا الامر وهذه
المساله وياخذونها بالاعتبار اعتقد اكثر
من اول ايه لانه صارت تقنيات اسهل
اعتقد انه كمان الجيل الجاي الشباب اللي
في الجامعات والمدارس اعتقد
يفضلو هذا التقنيه اكثر لانهم متعودين انه
الاشياء تخلص بسرعه يقدروا يعملوا اكثر
شيء بنفس الوقت فيمكن هذا يكون مطلب لهم
للجيل القادم لكن كمان احب شويه بس ابين
شويه سلبيات اذا تسمحوا لي لانه ساعات
العمل ما راح تقل فيعني مثلا موظف يشتغل
ثمان ساعات اليوم لمده خمس ايام في
الاسبوع حيصير يعمل عشر ساعات في اليوم
بدل ثمان ساعات في الاسبوع فهذا كمان ممكن
يرهق الموظف انه ساعات العمل اطول لكن
بالمقابل في يوم اجازه اضافه ممكن الوقت
يصير في ضغط اكثر انه يخلص الشغل في اربع
ايام اكثر من خمسه ايام فبلجيكا مؤخرا
عمله
عملوه قانونيا الموظف لو حريه الاختيار
اذا يعمل خمسه ايام او اربع ايام في
الاسبوع الموظف يقدر يختار فهذا يمكن
يناسبك ههه
طيب رشا اللي لفتني نقطه من الابرز
الايجابيات انه الموظف او الموظفين يصيروا
اكثر انتاجيه وفعاليه واكثر راحه نفسيه
بهذا النظام الى اي مدى تقنيات الحديثه
مواقع التواصل تساعد على ذلك انه نبقى على
التواصل المرد على التواصل مع العمل حتى
واحنا في البيت
طبعا التقنيات الحديثه سهلت يعني احنا
شفنا في وقت الجائحه الناس تشتغل عبر
القارات على على الزوم ولا على التيمز على
المكالمات الايميلات ما عاد ضروري وجود
الشخص في المكان لكن كمان عدم وجود الشخص
في المكان وعدم وجود بيئه العمل هذه كمان
تسبب شويه فتور يمكن في